Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
are marking 75 years of the nakpap or
catastrophe
winds are planned around the world
including at the un's headquarters in
New York in 1948 Palestinians were
forcibly displaced from their Homeland
to enable the establishment of the state
of Israel Zionist forces killed
thousands of Palestinians destroyed
hundreds of villages and expelled 80
percent of the Palestinian population
was sarakhilates at the demonstration in
ramallah's al-manata square talk us
through what's been happening Sarah
foreign
yeah well at the moment there's the
nakbar March which is held every single
year they have speeches as you can hear
just behind me we've seen Scouts pass
through with flags Palestinian Flags to
Mark 75 years where 750 000 Palestinians
were displaced more than 500 Villages
were destroyed and now the diaspora of
Palestinians that have now live outside
of Palestinian Landis looking at like
seven million Palestinians now this
situation hasn't changed but I want to
hand over to a Palestinian herself who
can talk more about what it feels like
to live under occupation we have in
Earth from the Palestinian Institutes of
public to put diplomacy how has things
changed for you over 75 years your
family were displaced you said many of
them now live abroad what does that feel
like for you and your family
yeah I would say for Palestinians the
nagba it never ended we talk about
ongoing
because if you see 5 million
Palestinians are still refugees my
family could never return to Palestine
and you will see people here who still
live in refugee camps who come to
commemorate what is effectively the lack
of Freedom that we still have and we're
still longing for return what does that
lack of Freedom look like on a daily
basis I mean the occupation is
increasingly taking more lands from
Palestinians what for our International
audience what does that actually mean on
a day-to-day basis so the mass expulsion
that happened in 1948 takes different
forms today the settler Colonial project
the colonial project of the Israelis to
replace the Palestinian native
population with Jewish settlers is
ongoing in different areas in
masafariata in beta in East Jerusalem
where you have many Palestinians just
fighting to remain in their lands and
many refugees who are still fighting to
go back to Palestine because we are one
people uh yesterday I was speaking to uh
an older lady she's in her 80s she was
talking about how they were displaced
from a place called a lid which is now
it's in Tel Aviv effectively she really
hopes for the right for return as
someone who's from a younger generation
what do you feel about that and what are
you doing especially with your advocacy
internationally to push that narrative
forward
yeah I think the rights of return is an
inalienable rights of the Palestinian
people and the new generation is still
you know fighting to return we're one
people so the the Israeli occupation has
deliberately fragmented Us in so many
Geographic areas in different
administrative ID and systems but what
we're doing today in the new generation
is fighting for the unity of the
Palestinian people and fighting that
forced fragmentation and basically
saying that the Palestinian culture the
Palestinian identity exists everywhere
in the overall Territory between the
river and the Sea thanks very much and
as well just earlier today one
Palestinian was killed in occupied West
Bank at a refugee camp which is one of
many one of 19 Refugee campsites run by
unra which is the UN Refugee agency and
these kind of raids we're seeing are
happening on a daily basis as well as
demolitions of Palestinian homes and
even schools which all goes against
international human rights back to you
Rob so thank you very much indeeda
sarakara talking to us from Ramallah
well let's hear from some of the
Palestinian refugees recounting their
stories of survival during their
they came in like a downpour of rain we
went and hid from the shooting which
continued until the next day then the
elderly women Youth and children stayed
until they entered the houses and took
us Prisoners the situation was
deplorable I cannot describe to you the
catastrophe that befell us we did not
get out easily or without loss our blood
was shed but until today I have not
forgotten any peace or inch of my
country
perhaps I will return to yaffa or our
homes in lead perhaps my grandchildren
or my children but we will definitely
return but when and how only God knows
that
we're going to bring in hananas she's a
Palestinian politician and Civil Society
leader she was previously a member of
the Palestine Liberation organization's
executive committee and she's joining us
on Skype from Ramallah very good to have
you with us on Al Jazeera I want to ask
you about the fact that the UN is
marking Knack but a how significant is
the fact that they are taking this move
it is of course significant in a more
symbolic way than any other way because
the UN has been acting symbolically but
not effectively however it is one
expression that says we do recognize the
nakaba we do recognize Palestinian
history Palestinian reality the disaster
the catastrophe the tragedy that we felt
the Palestinians at the creation of the
state of Israel on their land and
therefore it is the antidote to all
these disgusting celebrations at the
creation of the state of Israel as
though it was a masterful uh positive
creative event rather than looking at
the horror of the victimization of the
Palestinian people so this recognition
is important it's a message also that
the rest of the world have not forgotten
and that the rest of the world will
recognize our own identity our own
history and hands our own right I we
heard
I guess just a moment ago talking about
the fragmentation as she's sort of the
Palestinian people but Palestinians as
you were saying have long maintained
that they have a very distinct
Palestinian culture and identity how
much do you think this move by the U.N
and perhaps the growth of of marking of
this day around the world goes towards
acknowledging that identity
yes absolutely well our identity has
never been a doubt except by the
deliberate hasbara or spin campaign of
the extreme right-wing Israelis who
tried to erase our very narrative our
existence our rights in order to avoid
any kind of accountability over this
tragic Injustice that was done to us but
the world knows there was a Palestine
there were Palestinian people we do have
a distinct identity and culture and we
do have a Unity this is something that
Israel tried desperately to the story in
the sense that says if we fragment them
geographically if we find fragment them
in terms of the different types of
injustices under which they live that
they will either the old will die as
they said then the young will forget but
actually the Palestinians are extremely
possessive and protective of our
identity and history and culture
wherever we are so Palestinians and
refugee camps Palestinians and Exile
Palestinians under occupation a
Palestinian and within Israel we all
share the same vision not just the same
past but we speak the same language in
terms of our experiences our aspiration
and our dignity and our search for our
rights and for the Vindication of our
history so this experiment this attempt
at fragmenting the Palestinians
demographically geographically
Etc failed because we are insisted on
maintaining our own connectivity our own
Continuum as opposed to the Continuum of
the nakbar of the ongoing ethnic
cleansing
Endeavors and plans by Israel so it's
very important that we have remained
steadfast we have remained resilient and
we have remained persistent in facing
all these as well attempts at our
Erasure or our displacement and
replacement plan
thank you very much indeed for being
with us on aljazeera
you're welcome